à
bonjour et bienvenue à strasbourg au
parlement européen pour cette nouvelle
édition d' europe hebdo et le reportage
de la semaine s'intéresse aux catalans
qui veulent s'affranchir de madrid pour
former un nouvel état pourquoi ce désir
d'autonomie pour le savoir nous sommes
allés à vic petit village près de
barcelone mais d'abord l'actualité à
l'heure où françois hollande a annoncé
des nouvelles propositions pour sortir
l'europe de sa longueur nous nous sommes
posé la question y at il encore un
projet pour l'union européenne
relancé l'idée européenne et sortir
l'europe de sa langueur vaste programme
françois hollande a lancé l'an 2 de son
quinquennat par de grandes idées
réaliser une union politique lancée en
gouvernement économique européen capable
de faire converger les politiques des
vingt-sept ou la possibilité pour
l'union de lever un emprunt en son nom
propre enfin une communauté européenne
de l'énergie
rien de neuf sous le soleil en somme la
plupart de ces mesures sur déjà porté
par nicolas sarkozy
ah si une chose alors que le parti
conservateur britannique propose un
référendum sur la sortie de l'union le
président français s'est voulu rassurant
l'europe peut largement survivre sans la
grande bretagne puisqu'elle a existé
auparavant sans elle
un peu court non
alors y at il encore un projet pour
l'europe
et
y at il encore un projet pour l'europe
c'est effectivement ce dont nous allons
parler on a vu effectivement françois
hollande ouvrir la deuxième année de son
quinquennat par des annonces qu'on
connaissait déjà lors de son
prédécesseur et pour en parler c'est
graham watson qui nous a rejoint merci
d'être avec nous
vous avez vu ce reportage avec nous
quand vous entendez le président
français qui dit de la grande bretagne
que après tout on a pu vivre sans elle
au début l'union européenne donc il n'ya
pas de souci on survivent aujourd'hui
sans elle vous qui êtes un europhile
convaincu qu est ce que ça vous inspire
il est vrai que l'europe peut très bien
survivre sans la grande bretagne et la
grande bretagne que survivre sur
l'europe mais il est aussi clair qu'est
ce que pour une europe qui est vraiment
concurrentiel la grande bretagne apporte
quelque chose pour la grande bretagne
l'europe apporte beaucoup donc nous
sommes beaucoup plus forts si nous
sommes unis que si nous laissons cette
merveilleuse bagarre que font n'allons
bretagne et la france depuis la gare des
30 on nous inspirer je suis sûr que le
président hollande voulait chatouiller
son collègue monsieur cameron qui a ses
propres difficultés au sein de son parti
en ce moment mais je ne pense pas que la
grande bretagne soit sur le le seuil de
quitter l'union européenne pas du tout
alors il ya quand même le parti
conservateur qui a déposé une loi
proposant un référendum avant 2017 on
est quand même proche finalement et on
sait que vos confrères anglais ne
portent pas l'union européenne dans leur
coeur est ce qu'il n'ya pas un risque en
2010 est de voir les britanniques sortir
de l'union et devenir comme on dit le
51e état des états unis ce n'est pas le
parti conservateur qui a proposé un
référendum avant 2017 si certains
députés de son parti donc moi moi je
suis du parti libéral démocrate je
regarde ce qui se passe dans le parti
conservateur avec un peu de peine quand
même pour eux ce n'est pas simple et raf
est très facile mais je ne pense pas que
le pays soit en danger en ce moment
en partie parce que mon parti au
gouvernement faisant partie de la
coalition ne permet pas et un référendum
hausse dans le haut cours de ce mandat
oui nous avons dit clairement et on ne
permet pas mais on voit bien que que
monsieur cameron est un petit peu pris
au piège avec cette frange un petit peu
oui europhobe si je puis dire donc est
ce que cette coalition tient encore la
route finalement je pense que la
coalition tiendra la route parce que la
coalition a été fait pour une raison
très simple c'est faire sortir la
grande-bretagne de ses difficultés
économiques
il nous a fallu plus de temps de ce
qu'on croyait mais quand même ça va
tenir le coup jusqu'en 2015 c'est-à-dire
un parlement de cinq ans après on verra
mais avec le parti conservateur dont la
condition vous qu'il est maintenant je
ne suis pas sûr qu'il sera élu par le
peuple au gouvernement et donc on
pourrait très bien au visage ainsi se
voir non réélus votre part je
ne me fais pas trop de soucis jeu mais
je pense qu'on pourrait très bien
envisager un goût un autre gouvernement
à la prochaine fois en bois toilé sion
puis largement on voit bien que en gala
merkel est aussi pris au piège par
si je puis dire un calendrier électoral
qui n'est pas simple et pas très aisée
françois hollande est dans une quelques
difficultés après seulement une année de
mandat
cameron c'est pareil au fond est ce
qu'il n'ya pas un problème de leadership
en europe aujourd'hui est ce qu'on n'a
pas aujourd'hui pas on n'est pas
aujourd'hui en phase de leader qu'ils
sont qui regarde un petit peu tout cette
problématique d'un point de vue national
est-ce qu'il ya pas un prenne le
leadership
oui je pense que nous avons en effet un
très grand problème de leadership non
seulement nous avons les trois pays
principaux l'allemagne la france et la
grande bretagne qui ont leur propre
pression électorale et leurs propres
débats nationaux mais nous n'avons pas
une vision en commun pour l'europe et
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement ne
veulent pas mettre un visionnaire à la
tête la commission ou à la tête du du
conseil européen car il faut dire que
herman van rompuy n'est pas un
visionnaire j'ai un grand respect pour
monsieur vandromme paye mais un grand
visionnaire non je ne dirais pas et je
pense que les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement ont peur d'avoir quelqu'un
alors il faut et que les chefs d'états
et des gouvernements expliquent à leurs
concitoyens pourquoi il laisse l'europe
danseuse dans cette condition pourquoi
ils ne sont pas capables d'agir ensemble
car il nous faut agir ensemble pour
sauver l'économie de l'europe oui mais
là on voit bien que par exemple parmi
les propositions françois hollande y
avait cette espèce de gouvernement
économique de l'union est ce
qu'aujourd'hui les vingt-sept et bientôt
28 puisque la croatie rentrer au 1er
juillet les 27 pays vont être capables
de lâcher un petit peu de leurs
prérogatives pour un gouvernement
économique est une manière de travailler
ensemble sur les questions économiques
je l'espère for me et c'est vrai que
françois hollande a proposé ce
gouvernement économique mais en effet ce
que nous avons fait depuis 2008 depuis
la chute de lehman brothers c'est de
construire un gouvernement économique
que nous avons commencé avec une
architecture sur la dette publique avec
des tentatives de d'assainissement des
banques nous procédons maintenant avec
les procédures de résolution les banques
en faillite nous faisons toute une série
de choses au niveau 8 nous sommes en
2013 ça fait déjà cinq ans il ya une
autre proposition ce serait de créer une
forme de président économique enfin eu
donc je serai encore une nouvelle tête
est ce qu'il faut encore une nouvelle
tête une nouvelle institution j'ai
parfois l'impression que nous avons trop
de tête mais cette action on est là mais
nous avons un chef de l'eurogroupe qui
prend dans une certaine sens ce rôle
nous avons aussi grâce à dieu un
président de la banque centrale européen
qui est parfois beaucoup plus sage que
nos leaders politiques
que ce soit monsieur tricher ou que ce
soit monsieur draghi maintenant ce sont
eux qui ont tenu en route
l'économie européens danser dans les
temps difficiles où nos leaders
n'étaient pas capables toujours de se
mettre d'accord ben justement on va
continuer sur la question économique
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que la
france est entrée en récession deux
trimestres consécutifs de croissance
négative puisqu'il s'agit de l'appeler
comme ça mais ce qu'on ne sait pas trop
c'est que justement le tout la zone
économique européenne est en récession
depuis au moins six trimestres et on en
a parlé sur les télévisions étrangères
c'est un zapping préparé par aurélie la
face
0,2 pour cent de recul la france connaît
une croissance négative
l'europe s'en inquiètent plus ou moins
pour les gens cela ne change pas grand
chose que la croissance soit légèrement
au dessus ou en dessous de zéro pour
cent dans les faits elle est en dessous
de zéro pour cent ce qui signifie que
nous sommes en récession mais en vérité
ces dernières années la france a été en
gros dans la même situation sans
croissance simplement stagnante
en allemagne la journaliste dresse un
tableau noir très noir de la situation
française
les mauvaises nouvelles se succèdent la
france s'enfonce dans la récession
le pouvoir d'achat chute pour la
première fois en 30 ans et le chômage
augmente et augmente
les dirigeants européens aussi
s'inquiètent et attendent des réformes
le président de la commission européenne
l'a répété avec insistance il faut des
réformes structurelles en contrepartie
du délai supplémentaire de deux ans
accordée à la france pour ramener son
déficit sous la barre des 3% du pib la
commission attend de paris des réformes
dans le domaine des retraites et du
marché du travail notamment
graham watson depuis 2008 on annonce aux
européens finalement qu'on est sorti de
la crise et bientôt la fin de la crise
et c'est ce qu'on leur a menti
moi je n'ai jamais annoncé et je crois
avec monsieur sera ce que nous sommes
dans une récession qui va durer une
dizaine d'années nous sommes amis point
j'espère déjà nous avons fait certaines
choses qui sont nécessaires a aidé et je
l'y aider parce que les gouvernements ne
peut pas eu seulement
construire la croissance économique ils
peuvent aider la croissance économique
mais nous avons fait certaines choses il
va nous falloir faire d'autres choses
qu'on se finir la halle
architecture pour une europe qui sait
fonctionner qui contrôle la dette des
ses membres qui contrôle la
l'assainissement des banques qui qui
pourvoit la possibilité pour les
entreprises d'être des entrepreneurs
mais là est ce que l'on voit ça fait
quand même cinq ans maintenant que la
grèce est en récession le portugal c'est
pareil l'italie a des difficultés
l'espagne est-ce que l'austérité est une
solution pour faire redémarrer cette
économie moi je ne parle jamais
d'austérité parce que ce que nous nous
avons connue ce n'est pas vraiment
l'austérité l'austérité du passé c'est
la discipline budgétaire et c'est une
discipline nécessaire et voyez ça marche
déjà qu'est ce qui s'explique alors je
suis pas sûr que si vous dites aux grecs
que sa fondation oui mais oui qu'est ce
qui s'est produit dans les derniers
jours les agences de notation ont
commencé à dire que la grèce va venir
donc sa vie
politique par rapport aux agences de
notation et non pas par rapport au
peuple sait cela mais je fais un
politique par rapport au peuple mais
pour le peuple c'est une bonne chose que
l'économie de la grèce soit dans une
position de croître il a fallu faire des
choses très très difficile elle a fallu
couper les dépenses de l'état il a fallu
non on ne peut pas dire hausser les
impôts passe mais il a fallu que que la
grèce prend des impôts ceux qui ne
prenaient pas en avant donc il a fallu
l'état de l'art reste pour avoir la
possibilité d'une croissance économique
mais déjà avec le jugement des agences
de notation ça recommence on portugal
tout le monde en irlande ça recommence
nous avons facilité parce que nous avons
donné encore deux ans à un portugal et à
l'irlande pour se remettre en nombre
mais nous avons nous savons déjà que ça
marche alors dernière question
rapidement il a fallu trouver de
l'argent et on est en train de
s'attaquer aux paradis fiscaux on
annonçait déjà il ya quelques années que
c'était la fin des paradis fiscaux en
angleterre vous avez les îles de jersey
et guernesey est ce que pour vous ces
deux îles sont les paradis fiscaux et
est ce que la grande bretagne doit
arrêter de fadoua métro pas ces deux
îles à monsieur cameron a écrit une
lettre au chef de tous les choix dit
paradis fiscaux comme un fait j'en suis
sûr monsieur hollande a avec monaco
madame merkel avec liechtenstein il faut
que tout le monde règle ce qui se passe
parce que ce sont des centaines de
milliards d'impôts qui sont très
exactement merci c'est un gars à watson
d'avoir participé à notre émission de
toute façon continuera de suivre ces
dossiers nous on continue sur notre
lancée direction la catalogne un des
pays une des régions d'europe qui
souhaitent accéder à l'indépendance à
l'heure où l'europe va accueillir un
28ème état au 1er juillet prochain la
croatie donc direction barcelone avec
cécile siksou et sandra cerqueira
le sujet est partout il envahit les
conversations les journaux pour les
catalans devenir indépendant vire à
l'obsession
nous sommes à vic près de barcelone ici
tous sont persuadés que sans l'espagne
la catalogne serait plus riche et
vivrait mieux
cela fait trop d'années que l'état
espagnol nous étouffe la catalogne paye
chaque année à madrid 16 milliards
d'euros et en contrepartie on ne reçoit
quasiment rien en aide ou en
investissement pour la santé ou
l'éducation on paye trois fois plus que
le reste de l'espagne on n'en peut plus
de payer autant et de recevoir c'est peu
avec la crise les gens ouvrent enfin les
yeux on se rend compte d injustice
d'autant que nous aussi on a subi des
coupes budgétaires
aux fenêtres et aux balcons la bannière
indépendantiste frappé d'une étoile
blanche et fièrement accrochée et même
au fronton de la mairie le drapeau
espagnol a disparu
ici ce n'est pas l'espagne ici c'est la
catalogne on a été conquis par l'espagne
mais on n'est pas espagnol on est
catalan nous sommes une nation qui a son
identité sa langue sa culture
nous sommes à notre pays un pays qui n'a
pas d'état en 2009 le village s'est
déclarée état catalan libre suite à un
référendum populaire un vote pour
l'indépendance qui a eu lieu dans plus
de 600 villes de catalogne et à chaque
fois une majorité écrasante du oui pour
s'affranchir de l'espagne bien que
symbolique cette déclaration de
souveraineté a empiré les relations avec
madrid
c'est à ce moment là que le mouvement
indépendantiste s'est intensifiée en
catalogne madrid a très mal réagi ils
ont voulu interdire ce référendum
populaire en ayant recours à la justice
l'espagne affirme ex était
inconstitutionnelle parce que nous
n'étions pas une vraie nation et ça a
été très mal vécue par les catalans et
pour ne pas relâcher la pression le
village a décidé depuis peu de ne plus
verser ses impôts locaux à l'état
central ils sont récoltés directement
par la catalogne une façon de répondre à
madrid qui a toujours refuser à la
région catalane l'autonomie budgétaire
tant réclamée c'est un acte de
protestation et par la même occasion
nous préparons l'avenir et notre
indépendance c'est une sorte d' exercice
grandeur nature pour apprendre à
administrer nous même nos impôts nous
savons que nous ne pouvons attendre
aucune aide des espagnols car ce qu'ils
aimeraient sait garder notre argent
le processus d'indépendance se
concrétise à barcelone compose déjà les
bases pour la création d'un état depuis
un mois le conseil de transition
nationale travaille en toute discrétion
douze membres des politiques des
universitaires
ébauche les contours d'un fisc d'une
sécurité sociale d'une banque centrale
catalane et d'un pouvoir judiciaire
une feuille de route chargée en
attendant le référendum pour
l'indépendance prévue en 2014 par le
gouvernement catalan
n'a rien à voir avec le fait de gloire
des frontières ou de se replier sur
nous-mêmes au contraire c'est la
possibilité d'enfin faire entendre notre
voix à l'europe et à l'international et
de ne plus dépendre de l'espagne pour
décider de nos politiques enfin parler
d'égalé à égale avec madrid
le rapport de force avec madrid ne fait
que se durcir en réponse le gouvernement
espagnol continue d'affirmer que ce
référendum n'a aucune valeur juridique
il est clair que la constitution
espagnole ne reconnaît pas le statut
d'auto détermination pour l'instant on
va vers une rupture avec l'état central
mais nous sommes déterminés à demander
l'aide des tribunaux internationaux pour
faire reconnaître notre indépendance on
ne peut pas bafouer cette volonté
démocratique
solution pour les uns catastrophe pour
les autres l'indépendance fait peur aux
industriels catalan certains ont déjà
menacé de déplacer leurs sièges de
barcelone si le scénario
indépendantistes se confirme
c'est la région la plus dynamique du
pays et les exportations augmentent pour
cet économiste
ce n'est pas le moment de courir le
risque de perdre de l'activité pire de
réduire le pib
le risque en devenant indépendant c'est
que nous quittions l'europe nous
n'aurons alors plus l'appui de la banque
centrale européenne
être en dehors de l'union européenne
revient à payer des taxes et 60 % de nos
exportations sont à destination de
l'europe ce serait un surcoût
considérable qui plomberait notre
économie sans compter que les
entreprises catalanes ne sont pas à
l'abri d'un boycott de l'espagne plus
qu'un boycott l'espagne pourrait si la
catalogne quitte l'union européenne
bloquer le processus d'adhésion car il
faut l'unanimité de tous les pays
membres le chemin vers l'indépendance
pourrait être encore long
reportage de sandra cerqueira et cécile
siksou réalisé près de barcelone alors
comment comprendre ce souhait
d'indépendance y at-il un risque
d'implosion en europe nous en parlons
avec notre invité véronique de kaiser
bonjour un jour êtes députée européenne
d'origine belge membre de la commission
des affaires étrangères comment vous
interpréter ce souhait d'indépendance au
sein de l'union européenne est ce que
vous comprenez que les catalans ont tous
envie de quitter l'espagne et donc
l'europe
je comprend ce qui se passe en catalogne
parce que c'est pas elle même si tous
les nationalismes et toutes les volontés
d'autonomie ou d'indépendance ne se
ressemblent pas parce qu'il ya des
contextes historiques propres à chaque
pays y est même des facteurs qui sont
similaires dans les différents cas je
pense que il ya un fond
nationaliste et une histoire millénaire
en catalogne et la catalogne jusqu'il ya
peu avec pas mal gérée avec le
gouvernement central east de madrid
départ d'autonomie de plus en plus
grands largement monnayer c'est une
région riche qui le reste et puis la
crise est arrivée la crise est arrivée
et la crise p e partout et les
situations de ce type là c'est à dire
que tout à coup on va trouver comme on
le trouve en flandre chez moi comme le
trou peut le trouver en écosse les gens
qui disent oui mais
et on se sent différent on se sent avec
une identité propre et en plus on va
payer pour les autres et c'est en
général des régions riches qui dit ça
c'est plus un rejet de l'état tels qui
s'est constituée par les annonces et du
sien rejet de la solidarité c'est un
rejet ce n'est pas un rejet de l'europe
n'en fut pas au contraire l'europe
apparaît comme une ombrelle refuge oui
pourrait continuer à vivre en tant que
région indépendante ou que pays
indépendant c'est un relais de région
par rapport à l'état central bord pour
pouvoir à l'état central
mais ça ça a toujours été rampant mais
qui aujourd'hui se cristallise sur les
transferts de solidarité c'est-à-dire ce
sont les régions riches qui disent
aujourd'hui je ne veux plus payer pour
les plus pauvres chez nous les flamands
disent les wallons nous coûte une demie
mercedes chaque année dans chaque foyer
on paye parce qu'ils sont plus malades
que nous et vous le trouvez en catalogne
mais vous lui trouvez un écossais si les
gens disent mais on serait mieux si on
était tout seul mais ce qui est un peu
court mais ça me partie de raisonnement
alors si ça devait arriver qu'est-ce qui
se passerait est ce que si la catalogne
quitter l'espagne ça veut dire
obligatoirement qu'elle quitterait
l'union européenne est ce que les
traités prévoient un tel cas de
sécession et les traités ne ne prévoit
pas ce cas là et ce qui est sûr c'est
que l'union européenne ne peut de toute
façon
répondre qu'à la demande d'un état c'est
à dire automatiquement
ces nouveaux états qui se construirait
n'appartiendrait pas à lui nord la
roseraie normalement il demandé et pour
ça comme on l'a dit très justement ils
ont besoin d'une vote unanime du conseil
dont ils ont besoin quelque part s'ils
veulent le faire de s'entendre d'abord
avec leur ex pays parce que c'est l'ex
pays qui va donner le là évidemment si
demain les causes devait devenir
indépendante par exemple c'est sûr que
elle devra le faire sous le patronage
bienveillant de la grande bretagne je
suis pas sûr que la grande bretagne est
une fille que l'éco centre dans l'union
européenne ou qu'elle même peut y rester
mais c'est ça qui qui qui doit se passer
c'est à dire que sans avis favorable de
l'ensemble des pays de l'union
européenne ces pays là n'auraient pas de
chance de rentrer ce qui serait
évidemment très dommageable du point de
vue économique pour eux est ce que vous
craignez un risque d'implosion en europe
où vous pensez comme vous dites que ça
n'arrivera pas justement parce que les
traités le prévoit pas et peut-être
aussi parce que c'est ces petites
régions n'ont pas forcément les moyens
d'assurer l'eau les moyens financiers
d'assurer leur autonomie
je pense que si ça doit arriver si un
jour ça doit arriver quelque part ça
doit se faire à travers un long
processus qui est un processus de
conciliation avec le pays d'origine je
dirais les coups de force à mon avis ne
marcheront pas et je pense que la
plupart des acteurs le savent très bien
mais évidemment c'est pas ça le discours
qui vont faire passer ils doivent
d'abord provoqué un état de fait le dire
à la population donné envie de devenir
indépendant puis après de m dans un fait
accompli mais ce qu'un tel coup de force
comme vous dites peut arriver par
exemple chez vous en belgique
il est presque arrivé il est arrivé de
manière virtuelle que lorsque la radio
de chez la radio-télévision de chez nous
a annoncé par un faux journal parlé que
la belgique se divisaient et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que tout le monde ya
cru tout le monde ya cru et c est l
affolement général vous souvenez
sûrement de cette émission finances yves
luxe et imagina finadorm puisqu'on est
dans l'imaginaire des gens c'est très
possible maintenant si ça doit arriver
en belgique et c'est annoncé je dirais
le parti indépendantiste chez nous la nv
a fait dans le nord du pays c'est à dire
la partie flamande le score le plus
élevé c'est-à-dire plus de 30%
aujourd'hui d'estimation de vote c'est
énorme c'est le poids du parti
socialiste dans la partie wallonne du
pays et le premier paragraphe de la
charte de ce parti c'est l'indépendance
mais maintenant ce parti qui a un leader
remarquablement charismatique et qui est
intelligente et solidaire dit part des
choses très différentes bart de wever il
dit bombay ce n'est pas à l'ordre du
jour maintenant faisons des transferts
de compétences de plus important de plus
en plus importante là ces transferts de
compétences peuvent être le début d'un
éclatement de la belgique ou pas
et lui dit ça viendra en son temps il
parle et c'est très très intéressant
parce qu'il est un langage et qu'il faut
piste et il parle de l'évaporation de la
belgique la belgique va s'évaporer
peut-être que comme un celle qui il est
ni dit si on continue à faire des
transferts de compétences mais la
belgique va se creuser s'évaporer y aura
plus une belgique donc ça va se passer
tout seul donc surtout pas deux heures
surtout pas de panique on va très
doucement vers une autonomie de plus en
plus grande qui va finir par vider la
belgique et ça c'est un processus qui
est en marche là qui est dangereux pour
l'homme est ce que c'est c'est parti là
celui de bart de wever ou celui de le
parti catalan est ce qu'ils se
construisent aussi sur un rejet de
l'europe ou pas du tout vous avez dit
que c'était plutôt entre l'état sur un
rejet de l'europe le parti ils ont
besoin de l'europe isolement eu besoin
de l'europe ce sont des des européens
pur et dur nous avions d'ailleurs une
représentante de la nva parmi nos
collègues elle était une farouche
européenne ou non ce n'est pas en danger
un leader comme nigel farage en france
et mountain qui pâtissait veuillez
sortir la poudre aux yeux des billets
beaucoup de l'arrière en voyez vous il y
en a qui rejette l'europe il y en a qui
sont des partis d'extrême droite
racistes bo3 laisse pas populiste et
c'est le parti de bart de wever a été
fondée en belgique sur des parties qui
étaient extrêmement raciste extrêmement
populiste agressif et qui avait durant
les deux premières guerres collaboré
avec les allemands ça c'est aussi une
composante importante parce que les
allemands pour diviser les pays avaient
favorisé par tous les mouvements
indépendantistes et donc ils ont c'est
ce côté pro nazi qui faisait peur à tout
le monde de wever est arrivé ils
viennent ces parties là c'est un
électorat qui se reconfigurer mais lui
il a voulu éviter absolument ses
références mais dans sa symbolique dans
d'antan dans la manière dont il met en
scène ses discours tout rappelle l'ordre
nouveau en belgique tout rappelle les
moments où la droite flamande s'était
rapproché de l'ennemi donc
on retrouve tout ça mais avec des
variantes de pays à pays et c'est
certainement à mon avis
activé par la crise est activée aussi
par
l'incompréhension des citoyens
d'une europe qui est très lointaine et
qu'ils ne tiendraient par contre de
leurs particularismes je crois que il ya
cette idée de particularisme dans on est
différent et ont la mine nos différences
on est différent mais en vie ensemble
dans une même union européenne merci
beaucoup véronique de kaiser d' avoir
raisonné sur ce plateau d'europe hebdo
ainsi se termine cette émission on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine cette fois
à bruxelles mais toujours au coeur du
parlement européen très bonne suite de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires